hi
hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to welcome to the
game
hi everybody big warning before we get
started as with the first game
there was a lot of flashing lights
flashing colors so big epilepsy warning
and my god is this music at the
beginning of this game so
damn hype but i'm excited about this
game i mean
i don't know if it's actually going to
be a good game because the last game was
a little bit
i don't know tedious to say the least
but
this one should prove to be a little bit
more uh on the nose so
if you guys are ready i'm ready but once
again like i said people are just
joining me because this is
done live at first but uh big epilepsy
warning
also there's a weird little option that
says nudity yes no
and i've checked no to the nudity so i'm
sorry if you were looking for some sweet
nudes
in this one you missed out on the
calendar and you're gonna miss out on
this game so hi everybody let's get to
it
i don't know what to expect oh hey okay
all right well see ya
guess i'm going to go up into the sky
all right
this game is hard i would absolutely
believe that 100 because the last game
was pretty hard too
you are clint edwards an investigative
reporter for one of the leading online
news sites you're investigating the
mysterious disappearances murders
related to the deep web
you're deep in your case and about to
make a breakthrough but then you get a
call from someone
least expected pro tip disconnecting
from a network will prevent you from
being hacked
tracked by the police why would i be
track
why would i be tracked by the police i
don't think i why would why would that
be a thing
all right am i loading or is this is
this a loading screen oh
okay 2016. call log through
okay i guess i'm not reading that uh oh
adam no wait what what am i working with
here
huh i can't leave yet can i read that no
okay i guess i gotta talk to adam
adam hey what's up i heard you were
looking for me uh-huh
check this out it might help you on your
case uh-huh yeah
what are we looking for what are you
talking about check this out
oh okay notes this is
what we just went live and it's trending
on the back channels i've been
moderating for the past
hour and every so often a different girl
shows up asking for help
they think they are streaming to their
face page but it seems that people
holding them are rerouting their stream
to this platform they might be cutting
off all cellular data except for their
face page
at least that's what i think they are
doing it seems to be some sort of voting
platform
the viewers seem to be taking votes for
something
i guess it's not good
well you don't know that you could be
wrong also your your subtitling is way
way behind your actual speech patterns
there
all right i don't know what you could
you could assume that a website by the
name of dead or not
you know it could be good oh wait oh oh
no
here comes the new girl oh how do you
know how do you know
oh oh my name is amelia lewis someone is
kidnapped me
i don't know where the [ __ ] i am it's
it's dark and freezing
i think there's blood on the floor
hmm not a lot of people seem to want to
vote for
not i'm a shadow web i was
just researching something and i found
this
cult called the the prey
i think um i don't know what happened
after that i i just saw these these
[ __ ] up
images and these men in masks and
then i woke up here
hello i need to hide
i'm sorry i just getting on the shadow
web is a task on its own
the shadow web is a whole level of the
deep web it requires special software
which is not easy to get
she mentioned the prey which is
interesting because they mostly operate
on the normal deep web
i have a feeling that she might have
stumbled across something more sinister
and they're using the prey as a front oh
really yeah
okay all right something even more
sinister in the shadow web than the prey
all right the reason the reason i
laughed at that is just because
the first instinct you have when you
hear
womb is not hello
huh is someone there
when you hear whom you go
and run at the opposite direction as
fast as you can because that can't be
good
it just it's not good no matter what you
do
oh well she's back i don't know he saw
me but
it's definitely them he was wearing the
same mask
i don't know how the [ __ ] they got to me
but they did
they did that they did that did that
they got to you
okay all right well it's coming please
hurry my battery's dying
it seems familiar just like you she
might have dug a little too deep and
caught the attention of some twisted
individuals
she keeps on mentioning men in masks
which reminds me of a document i read a
while back
you're more of a cult no one really
knows their official name
online we refer them to as noir
i'll send you that document to your
desktop amelia seems to have a great
deal of information
it could be a huge resource to your
investigation mm-hmm let me see if i can
source up the shadow web tunnels you
still have across
okay whatever you say man what do you
say adam i'm here to support you
i'm here to support adam also who is
adam how do i know adam and why is adam
helping me
and why is their name noir why does it
seem like uh
what what was his uh uh uh some the
precursor to simalacra
this seems a lot like that too oh
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
i think he's gone yeah okay yeah
jump scare oh there it is
that's that sound hmm
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
i'm in some kind of warehouse or
facility
i don't know there are [ __ ] maniacs
here
please they haven't gotten to me yet but
if they do please tell my parents i love
them
and i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't mean to
laugh
okay i managed to source up the tunnel
place it on your desktop
unlocking this should reveal the
location of where she's being held
okay
oh my god was so funny just adam
just nonchalantly after everything that
happened like just
like tell my parents i love them
okay all right i managed to source up a
tunnel
i'm sorry i shouldn't be laughing at
this but god damn it it's fun
acting
okay what am i doing noir tunnel ah
something seems suspicious about
this icon right here is locked using a
shadow web encryption
key the key will be broken down to eight
different hashes
you must explore the deep web and find
these hashes of course
the hidden hash will look like this
is that is that a is that what i'm
supposed to can i write that down
it's gone it's just gone okay
so if you were to find a cache that
begins with the number one
it will be the first sequence in the
master key
uh-huh okay so it's a lot like the first
game you need to go around you get
hashes
you write them down in your notepad
could be hidden anywhere on a page
why is that a balsa be sure to check the
page
thoroughly hover your mouse over
everything and see if we'll activate a
hidden hot zone
i would even check the page's source
code if i were you
another great deep web some pages will
only be available during a certain time
window
so if you come across a page that is
down be sure to check back later
[Laughter]
okay good luck
thanks adam thanks bro thanks man you
have a good day i'm gonna go off and die
on the deep web
all right see you dude you have a fun
time all right let's read these
documents um intercept cable run
zero numbers [ __ ] attention precinct
64 tactical pockets of illegal activity
have begun to appear over a monitored
deep web nodes
be on the lookout for increased traffic
in your networks in accordance with the
department's new cyber crime
initiative warrants for forced entry
will be given expedited approval
ccu will be filtering deep web activity
based on a heat map data of illegal
sites visited in attempts of felonious
activity
further investigation will be conducted
on the proposed suspects and a warrant
issued if found necessary
investigators also concluded that
individuals who constantly switch
networks are not traceable
okay use of force and disorienting
devices permitted
well i don't know about that one you
should probably shouldn't just run in
guns blazing but what do i know all
right
let's see intercept cable lucas kumiegov
poland lucas served six years in the
polish land forces before recruitment
into the jw grom where he further served
an additional seven years
lucasian made the transition into the aw
before his disappearance it was later
discovered that kumiga had been
receiving
payment for polish government secrets
involving operations with the us via
cryptocurrency through transfer services
on the deep web
once an investigation had been opened it
was soon learned that lucas had been
responsible for illegal torture and
other violent war crimes kumiga was
terminated from the
aw and charged with treason upon being
charged kumiga fled poland and is
believed to be providing contract
killing services through his deep web
contracts
intelligence has yet to be able to
provide a location of lucas gumiega
though
field agents have been attempting to
connect reports of seemingly
random homicides involving 4th century
with fatal gunshot wounds to the head
and fatal gunshots wounded to the head
through the victim's front door
a very small number of reports believed
to be the cia to be the same killer have
surfaced from individuals who have
managed to hide while the attacker
entered their homes
grabbing a ball man in a suit hit man
while the cia has reasons to believe
this man is lucas cumiego
the reports are not from locations all
over the world and yet to be connected
to one place of origin
okay all right so i'm gonna be shot if i
look through my door probably through
the peephole i'm gonna be shot right
through the head which would be great
noir it doesn't matter who i tell or
what i say no one believes me and i know
they will find this and delete this the
government will deny that noir exist
to keep simple minds at ease but i know
the truth i just hope one illuminated
mind seizes before it's too late
i know they're gonna kill me i've read
how they do it and it's happening to me
now
the phantoms appearing in the corner of
your eye only to vanish into the
darkness
letting you know that you've been chosen
if you find your vows looking over your
shoulder do not linger in the dark they
will find you
if you approach a man in a ghostly mask
run and hide
if you don't you are in their trap and
you are already dead
i heard if you turn away from them and
show your back count from 30 they
disappear
wait wait a minute wait
hello what kind of supernatural [ __ ]
is this breather okay
breather december 3rd police respond to
a call reporting a man wearing a hoodie
in what appears to be a surgical mascot
during a alleyway followed by
pounding sounds and screams as
describing by the caller
investigators found the body of 27 year
old charles roberts dead inside a
building attached to the alley
the case detective reports roberts tried
to escape by hiding in the billy's back
entryway but damage to the door and
clear signs of struggle
inside the building suggests the
attacker managed to kick in the door and
overtake roberts
the coroner report the coroner
report reveals that the victim has
suffered 13 stab wounds to the abdomen
and neck okay zone one
you guys hear that
i heard that
i'm hearing that you guys hear that
oh boy instructions
oh no stop the green sliding blocks in
the red dots okay easy enough test hack
let's try this bad boy
oh okay i'm ready
i'm ready oh i see okay
oh i did it i'm the best i'm the goddamn
best in the world
so these are all the different uh ways
that i can get
hacked you must memorize and repeat the
sequences like this oh
okay let's try this one
easy enough that's a lot of this game
it's going to be just like hacking games
one zero
easy peasy i'm the best okay easy enough
got this stack pusher
all right you'll be presented with a
stat grip to successfully defend you
must
stack overflow attack using security
passed over the popper node
you hear that
you guys hear that hang on let me turn
up the volume for you just because like
the uh
the the beginning of it was loud because
of the music but
now everything's like subtle and i don't
like it you guys seen
this range okay all right okay
all right then overall strategy is the
swiftly pushing the node stacks closer
to the popper node
okay all right um
sure i'm not 100 sure successful
push
what what
maybe maybe i'm a goddamn fool
oh boy
what wha what
what i don't i don't understand this at
all what the hell is this one supposed
to be
oh i see
okay so that allows it to go closer oh
okay all right then easy enough and the
last one is node
hexer the node hexer tool you'll be
presented with networking nodes
currently associated with your
connection these networking nodes will
constantly change the node network will
look like this oh my god alpha node beta
node
solve the connect the corrupted nodes oh
my god
i don't know how to do this initiate a
connection node you must hover your
mouse over the connection protocols
inside the nodes click on the direction
if you want the node to connect to
what what why
you must you're pre-allocated no you're
pre-allocated with the current amount of
time to solve the node network each
connection you make to the crop
will give you extra time okay
all right okay i guess
[Music]
okay so okay so it must
it's supposed to alternate like
different
is that what it's supposed to do oh well
i'm well all right
okay i'm sorry okay all right
sorry i wasn't ready i didn't know which
one i was supposed to click
clack that's not what i wanted all right
whatever it's just can i please there we
go this is real sticky
that's real sticky that's real stick
stacky
did i do it did i dunz it what
what the [ __ ] did i get it why
didn't i get it
which is just a bunch of all right fine
let's try that let's try that let's try
that let's try that
let's try that that
that and that okay do i keep going
what do i do get out of here what the
freaking hell
how do i i'm not stupid i'm i might be
stupid well i'm i might be incredibly no
that's not what i wanted go go
go i don't know
so it does have to alternate it does
right it does have to alternate
i'm gonna why is this see see how this
doesn't oh my god are you kidding me
this control is [ __ ] this controls
[ __ ] hang on
no that's not what i wanted there we go
hang on wait no
i'm not this bad shut up i'm fine this
is so
stupid okay here we go no that
yes that and then that and that and then
that and then sure let's go that okay
i think that's what i'm supposed to do
oh oh well i just
i was just done oh my god
hello friend how are you doing all right
let's do this whatever this is oh this
is easy
nope
[ __ ] oh no my weakness
it it's so it's rather
difficult to get it no it's it is
surprisingly difficult to get
surprisingly difficult
it's
it's you can't click on them you can't
you can't click on them you can't click
this it won't let you click on them
how can you hack not do when you can't
click on
oh they stole my money
okay
i don't like that one all right let's
start the goddamn game and get on the
goddamn internet
and apparently they can steal your notes
which is [ __ ] but let's just get
into the game
cause this is [ __ ] all right where
are we going baby
where we going let's go surf the
internet let's do this bad thing
let's okay well real slow all right real
soon how do i look behind me by the way
how do i wait how do i how do i
oh there we are
okay all right how do i get up can i get
up
welp oh there i am oh
it's free roam it's like the joy of
creation up
hmm peculiar very strange
i don't like it can i
i gotta take a mean whiz why
oh i'm just hiding in there
peek-a-boo peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo oh wait my oh the mic
the mic oh
no one's here by the way this game picks
up my mic so if i'm talking and
jabbering and flabber babbin
while there's an enemy in my apartment
i'm kind of [ __ ]
i'm gonna be a little [ __ ]
okay all right then well where am i
supposed to
really okay all right then all right
sure
whoa it's pee-pee poop anybody there
okay all right i'm not about to be shot
perfect can i go outside oh
hello
well this is bizarre didn't expect me to
be free roman
but here i is hello neighbor neighbor
neighbor neighbor never never never
never okay
oh it keeps going
okay
okay so i think i'm wasn't i 806 oh [ __ ]
god damn it why are there why are there
so many minigames hide me
oh okay all right why are there so many
minigames in this
why is it so expensive how the frick are
you supposed to
win oh no
why are there children's drawings on the
ground
can i get to the roof why why would
there be
why is there maintenance on every floor
this is incredible
oh boy okay all right i can't go out
there
all right fine then i know i shouldn't
be exploring before i actually try to
like dive into the
the the internet in the first place but
man this is
this is weird i don't even why am i am i
supposed to like run away from someone
through the hallways and then somehow
make my way back to my own house
my own apartment and then you know try
to live
i don't know man i don't know this just
seems like a death trap why would i come
up here
why don't i come is this it for realism
oh no i don't know
i don't know i don't know all right i
don't even remember what floor i was on
it wasn't this one it was one with the
maintenance store i think it was right
here let's just get back to the computer
because there's far too much here
to worry about oh we're gonna die
we're gonna die you don't win yeah
pretty sure yeah
pretty sure not gonna win yeah okay wait
wasn't this my
no
here we go all right this one's mine let
me just
lock the door no one will be able to get
in now
right what else we got here seize date
2016. all right couple thumb drives
got flashlight audio recorder can't use
that
all right why do i have a balcony
why do i need a goddamn balcony oh this
torch does nothing
ooh fire escape okay oh i guess i can
leave oh
man i don't like that i don't like that
at all
all right okay enough enough enough
fiddle [ __ ] around we gotta get onto
the internet and we gotta die horribly
can i at least lock my balcony door
why do none of my doors have locks that
need the locks
all right whatever we're good we're good
we're good can i read this now there we
go multiple calls from unknown caller
cellular network heavy breathing only
always a call at 10 pm through the voip
via voice over ip the night of the
incidents who's adam
you good good good good question good
question who what the hell
what what
what's is that my wi-fi i don't know
whatever let's just get back on the
computer
we got this i think can i
nope apparently i cannot okay let me sit
take a [ __ ] here
hmm oh there we go oh that's my computer
oh it's tiny that's adorable
okay unable to connect let's do this
refresh
no hmm
well that don't seem right adam's
twitter what
is my internet out what oh
i didn't i'm just connected to the
internet why do you want to hack me so
badly oh god here we go
okay whatever shut up all right you're
not gonna take my money this time oh
easy
easy peasy i got this one nope
miss hoop
okay got that one oh [ __ ] yeah
oh hack blocked your ass all right here
we go let's try this again
the web pro something tells me this guy
adam ain't no web pro
and something tells me that adam is
gonna end up
dead bro i don't have a
i don't have a login
is this actually wait is this like a
real working twitter
i bet it is i bet it oh look it is
oh my god there whoa [ __ ] are they gonna
[ __ ] with my game
ah they're probably gonna [ __ ] with my
game there they're probably gonna [ __ ]
with my game
they're probably gonna hmm
[Music]
weird as weird as in the game because
it's not that bad but him
a little weird well
let's see what's going on uh uh-oh well
that's not good oh kim kardashian ooh
fortnite carrie underwood
all right well i'm just gonna go back to
my home page here
okay here we go deep web fresh new links
great
okay all right happy family i like that
that's good
let's go to happy family all right
okay unable to connect
oh
um
okay okey-dokey
let me just pick it up
all right
i think i just gotta go restart the
power let me check what apartment number
i am again
803 great
i'm not dead yet i'm not dead yet and i
don't see the microphone symbol so i'm
assuming
i'm assuming i just gotta pop this bad
boy back in there
pop this bad boy back in here all right
803.
here we go
all right okay
all right we're fine everything's fine
everything's good
everything is fine everything's fine
everybody
everything's so unbelievably fine
all right all right let's get back to it
like nothing ever happened like
like nothing ever happened like like
nothing happened
like like not a damn thing happened all
right let's try this bab oh i gotta
connect to the internet again
okay all right we're good let's just go
into it
like nothing happened okay
oh still no internet that's weird oh
wait no that's because i was on that
weird site that wasn't working
all right well let's try this again
all right ave satan sure
let's go there that's a community who
like to exchange stds
okay that doesn't work all right that
one don't work that's no good
see the thing is i don't know in the
first game there was a bunch of
instances where
like websites were only available at
certain times
so i don't know when what's available
when
but whatever let's just try to
ooh excellent hello baby
welcome back hey how's it going if
you're new here we are a safe place for
your men and women
looking for a bug or looking group
[ __ ]
that's no good and no bueno all right
gotta check
everything join now you know i want to
you
you know i do you know i do cause like
with this game in the first game
it was so unbelievably hard because you
just have to nice butts
nice but oh tell us about you and mail
uh uh uh loves
loves demaids you know me loves demaids
at
std.com all right what are you looking
for
well well you know me so well
all right why do you want to join i
really
want aids that's it all right submit
that bad boy
all right good i feel good about myself
you guys feel good about this
sure sure do all right let's
well [ __ ] um that's a problem
leave lee let's leave
bad things are gonna happen guys oh
[ __ ] wait would this have
no it wouldn't maybe
i don't know man there's so much
[ __ ] store
store what do you have injectable
syringe
of gonorrhea gonorrhea
oh no oh god that's a horrible spit
semen ooh
[Laughter]
i don't want to click on any of that
nope
bad bad very bad no not good that's what
you would call not good
no not good
i think i'm gonna vomit all right bug
chasing hard to believe you are here and
don't know
if that's okay that's okay sweetie okay
um not seeing any clickables here
my entire time wasted here okay i didn't
want to be here in the first place i'm
audi i'm just audi i'm i'm outy if there
even is a
code in that one i ain't gonna find it
i ain't gonna find it cleaning let's
just hang on listen my gut [ __ ] pills
all right white supremacy site no
description really need to do
share your genitals might want to avoid
this
okay all right the granddaddy nope
just a whole lot of nope nope happy
family let's go to happy family
i'll go to father donald later i think
final fa
final daughter father donald last time
was
it was one i hate how long it takes to
is there a way to increase my web
surfing speed i know there's like a
store
maybe i should visit the store i only
got seven dollars so it's not like i can
buy a lot but let's see
i forgot to mention about dos coin das
coin is a crypto
no oh [ __ ] i was just trying to move the
uh all right
dos coin is a cryptocurrency used on the
deep web
you will need dot coin to purchase
upgrades and items to help you on your
way if you look at
the top left corner of your screen this
is how much dash coin you currently
have to help you out a little bit there
you go i went ahead and purchased you a
remote vpn
thank you i don't know what that means
vpn is a device that generates you
dasgoing during a certain period of time
hackers will rent these devices from you
to do their needs
depending on the location you place it
at will determine the amount of dos coin
you generate
so be sure to place it at a good
location here what's that complex
you can see what it generates under the
dos coin menu by clicking on the dos
coin logo
now any hardware item you purchase from
the shadow market will be delivered via
deep web drone
to your dead drop location this is where
your remote vpn is now located
to get there simply exit the lobby once
you have picked up the package
the items will be available to you in
your apartment so be sure to look around
your apartment when you get back from
the dead drop
oh okay that's about it that's not right
don't like that don't like that no
remote vpn's active
okay let's go make some money let's go
make some i'm gonna hide it again
let's go make some money let's make some
money everybody let's make some goddamn
money
that's what this must be right that's
what this must be
right it must be okay so there's gotta
be a good oh what the [ __ ]
i am dead
hello hi ow my gut hey whoa hey
whoa hey excuse me sir excuse me
what did i do
[Music]
what did i do no
what did i do
oh my god how what was the sign for that
was it the tax was it the garbo
text huh
[Music]
all right
i didn't hear that what was that
i was getting off the computer i was
i was in the process i was in the
process of getting off the computer what
did i do
wrong
all right anyway yeah listen for sound
thank you
i don't know what the sounds are in this
game excuse you
i don't know everything that you think i
know
my brain is empty all right so we just
need to hang up on
we're going to go put this bad boy wi-fi
dongle no
get off and shut up go away all right
we're going to get up
we're going to take this bad boy and
we're going to place it somewhere
let's see let's go to the roof let's go
to the roof
there's got to be a there's got to be a
good one on the roof right
right we've got to be change the wi-fi
i don't know about that i don't know i
don't think so
that seems oh well all right then i
guess we're here now
can i break into your apartment excuse
me would you like a vpn
i'm pretty sure this is how vpns work
probably
how about out on my patio that seems
good let's go right there
anybody want to use my vpn poink all
right i don't know what that did but i'm
assuming it was good
all right let's see here let's let's
change the y free wi-fi no virus
that doesn't seem right no vpn's
activated what
but i but i thought but i thought for
true
wait how do i activate my vpns
that doesn't make any sense at all this
doesn't make any sense at all
ah oh all right fine
i forgot to mention about dos coin das
coin is a cryptocurrency used in a deep
web
you will need das coin to purchase
upgrades and items to help shut up
we know this top left corner of your
screen shut up i know this vpn is a
device shut up
i know that okay so let's get to free
wifi
hmm
okay this one i like that i like that
okay vpn level one
key q oh ah that's handy
that's pretty much the only way that i'm
ever gonna win
all right bam i can break some wi-fi's
that's gonna be good for me because if i
keep connecting to wi-fi's and being all
stupid
then i'm gonna die right sorry you
couldn't see that but they're good
jane's wi-fi i will as soon as i can
break into him
i will i promise promise upon pinkies
you got go to the lobby i don't have
anything yet i gotta wait for this
this is all installing this isn't part
of the shadow market the shadow market's
different
okay wait did i just put my wi-fi dongle
outside
that wasn't my vpn was it does my wi-fi
that was my wi-fi uncle i just put my
wi-fi don't go out on the patio
oh oops my bad oh well
what do you what what can you do about
it what can you do ah who knows
what is noir tunnel oh i don't have that
yet okay
all right then well i'm sure that's
gonna do a lot of good out there let's
just disconnect to that
all right is this my is this my vpn or
where's my vpn where did you put me is
it in the lobby is it in the lobby you
guys you guys have probably been yelling
at me about that but it's probably in
the lobby
i got it don't worry don't worry guys
i got this i'm going to the lobby let's
all go to the lobby
ah i see that's why he sent me a free
one so that i could make some mons
and if i can make some mons i'm gonna do
good
no one's gonna get me jesus oh i guess i
was on the eighth floor
good god this seems like a huge waste of
time
lock my i didn't lock my door oh [ __ ]
well the [ __ ]
all right well too late for that all
right how do i get to the lobby
lobby lobby
lobby lobby lobby because it's so
far do i package for moi
hello uh oh this don't seem good
hello i don't like this coffee
doughnut can i hack into your computer
please
oh system locked but i can't do anything
about that okay someday i'll actually be
good at hacking
but today is not that day hello package
for moi
anything i
oh i'm outside now
oh
the future is now
wowie wowie wow
okay uh i guess that's good where is
this
what the well this is why did i just go
into this horrible closet
i don't understand what is happening
where'd the door go i didn't pick up the
flashlight
i've done so much wrong oh
i'm here now okay all right everything's
fine
everything's fine can i use the elevator
does the elevator work i don't want to
climb the stairs
i don't need that much exercise please
let me
[Laughter]
noise noise noise noise yeah i know okay
i got the vpn so that's probably
available up in my thing
so i can start making some dogecoin
that's gonna be good for me
it's gonna be good for me you guys you
guys are worried about this but it's
gonna be good for me
it's gonna be good watch out for stream
snipers
yeah i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
this is like the epitome of places for
which width to with which to stream
snipe
i don't remember what floor okay i'm
thinking it's gonna be this one
uh boosky a habooski
wait floor good god man going outside
for that [ __ ] is gonna take forever
if we have drone technology they could
just fly it into my alley
they could just fly it up to my room ugh
all right whatever it's fine
i don't think anybody knows i'm onto
them yet so i don't think they're going
to be coming after me
it's 803. all right anybody break in
here am i steal my [ __ ]
lock anybody okay i've got
where where is it where's my vpn
didn't i cold
cold cold hot cold where's my vpn
this is my vpn
ah okay all right then
i've got a vpn so what do i do with sad
vipin
hmm what do i do with it do i got to go
out again
hello i locked it hello does anybody
want a flippin
i've got a weapon i don't know stop
saying i'm screwed i'm not screwed
there's no one after me
yet let me go up to the roof i don't
think i can get to the roof
i'm gonna try i don't know what this is
gonna do for me hello
no okay all right then
uh could have shoulda woulda yeah could
have shoot it with a lot of things
i could have shoulda would have like
learned how to play this game before i
started this but
okay
all right then i got that up there no
one's going to suspect a thing
people are just going to think it's a
key bad to get up onto the roof and then
they're like no it doesn't work oh well
i'm gonna pass on moves you on
all right well now that we got our vpn
hopefully that's gonna make us some
money and then we're not gonna stay on
the same wi-fi for too long because
that's how the police get you
i don't know what this i don't know why
anyone would want to like assassinate me
just yet but you know
say lobby i guess all right so let's see
if that's actually working
habush okay i'm making money
oh you can't see hang on wait watch this
boom baby look at my
money oh yeah look at my money climbing
up
oh hell yeah is there any way to upgrade
that because that is slow going
that's slow going there's got to be like
um
okay all right i think we're fine
okay all right let's connect to one of
these bad boys
okay initializing all right
uh
this help help
okay select which cracker you would like
to use okay let's look
wep wep
uh
that oh
oh oh my god this is gonna be impossible
how do you do this okay all right
um okay
oh my god uh
uh okay
my goodness okay probe
no
probe let's see and valid use a probe
okay
so i need to
sk let's just scan scanning
anything no good god this game would
take like hours and hours of like
methodical bullshitting okay
so we've got the wi-fi id
we've got the bsid which is actually
what we need to put into the thing
channel 7 power 70 okay what was the
what was the layout again you need to do
you need to probe it start port end port
how do you find how do you find the
ports
oh one to a thousand okay all right okay
okay probe bs id is
i wish i could make this bigger there we
go there we go okay probe
uh
whoa what the [ __ ]
hiding hiding yet
okay i think we're okay
i think we're fine
i think we're fine that was just a
random gunshot
there was just someone you know just oh
la dee da
i shouldn't look in here okay we're fine
we're fine apparently okay
all right all right then you know what
yeah
i i think i'll figure this out later
because i don't even understand what's
going on here i don't want to know
you know i don't want to know i'll just
take the free wi-fi
i'll figure out the le the rest of it
later i guess
all right let's just go on the internet
huh
do that wait oh i'm still making money
okay
all right okay all right okay
let's just we're gonna connect to the
internet
and we're just gonna hope for the best
because that's that's all we can hope
for
here let's go homepage
don't like it don't like it don't like
it and i still gotta wonder if the
developers are gonna try to
try to bathroom cams no thank you all
right
fortune cookie tester [ __ ] you i wanna
go to [ __ ] you
yeah let me go to [ __ ] you all right
hang on gotta find out what [ __ ] you's
all about
why can't i make this there we go whoa
too big okay that doesn't work can't go
to [ __ ] you it
said fuggy to me and shut the door all
right
man sky break was not worth it if i
don't even know how to use it
okay come on come come on come on uh
milk supply storefront for breast milk
um
no no no i'm not gonna go there um
your data all right your data
um the door is locked it is locked i
think
i'm pretty sure all right none of these
goddamn websites work
not a goddamn one of these goddamn
websites are gonna work
i i know i i wanna hack the wi-fi but
it's just i'm very
scared hot burners all right let's try
that
there sure are a lot of satanism worship
sites that's a problem
probably unable to connect
god not a single one of these work not a
single one of these work and my wifi is
so
slow my internet is garbage
all right after this next one i'm gonna
change the the the
just random gibberish okay thanks for
visiting oh sure why not
uh shut the door the door is shut stop
you're making me paranoid thanks for
visiting oh that's nice
nice bear don't talk to me is there
going to be notes here to take
i'll take some notes if you want me to
what does that circle mean
don't talk to me that way chantelle
okay all right i don't know what this
website
is i don't know what this website is
oh thanks okay is there's gotta be like
a secret here there's gotta be one of
these
in here that actually does something
right it wouldn't just be a freaking
bear and a t-shirt
tell me to not talk to me that way it's
gotta be stop
no
i'm gonna get swatted i'm gonna get
swatted
was that a thing i don't know if that
was a thing
i don't wanna share my genitals
okay hang on wait okay
none of these slide wait slide wait
slide we're going to a different place
i don't know if it's going to be a good
place but we're going to a different
place
you should leave i don't know baby
shrimp i don't want to leave
i'm going deep
oh shrimp choose your shrimp wisely i
don't know
i choose this shrimp
damn it no
but it was doing so good
okay i can go back to the baby shrimp
good god i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
all right wait let's leave it here hang
on we're gonna go hey let's disconnect
from
this let's disconnect just disconnect
okay we're gonna change it
because i got bad field i've got a bad
feeling about my wi-fi hang on let's
change this up all right give me that
give give give
give you give to me give to me open up
open up
okay put this over by the bed let's get
a different free wi-fi perfect
easy peasy oh wait no perfect perfect
there we go
okay all right let's try this again
the baby shrimp
duty all right baby shrimp we got this
can i
like favorite this one yeah i can right
let's favorite that one
we're going to stick it baby shrimp all
right choose your shrimp
what do you guys think this shrimp
posture
did i do good
oh oh wait if you want to have good
posture and everyone does here's some
helpful posture do i sit tall with flat
feet on the floor
do i sit with my buttocks against the
lower back of my chair no
hold my head up high and keep my chin up
marianne at style i don't like that
walk with my legs closer swinging them
from the hip joints
walk letting my heel hit the ground why
not
very very good very good very good very
good
very very good everybody we're very good
we did very good
ah
evil monster i don't know what that is i
don't know what i want
to do door what about the door
why are you guys talking about the door
i don't want to go to the door what's
with the door
what's going on with the door did i lock
the door huh
check on the door okay everything's fine
don't tell me you're
talking about that door okay
everything's fine
everything's fine you guys are making me
paranoid
it is locked it is the mystery of the
evil monster by toby
hebelman once upon a time there was an
ugly man he lived in caves
he was half man and half monster and he
ate gorillas for food when he was hungry
when he was three he was very nice but
when he turned 12 he turned into a
monster
his name is the purple caveman monster
but he also is an alien his home plan is
called ook pop
he has a rocket ship and it can go 9
million miles a day then he went to
earth thursday in 1983
he landed in a lake inside forest and
his ship sink
any of these clickable probably one of
you is clickable
i know one of you is going to be
clickable oh i know it
i'm shocked i haven't been hacked yet
see landed inside the legs
and you saw a man named the president
the president fainted but he was under a
spell
before he was fully under the spell he
whispered wait he whispered to the
purple
caveman monster told him he was under
the control of wizard but it wasn't a
wizard
it was just that he was scared of the
purple caveman monster's ship crashing
in front of him so when the president
got angry for that he
shot a laser at him but the president
dodged it the end
what what
it is locked don't click here well you
know um
don't click there fake main
but this says fake main don't talk to me
what wait no
wait
[Music]
but wait
oh the door is locked guys the door
is locked i swear i swear upon a star
okay so what does this lead to it just
leads back into a circle
check the door nah nah it's fine there's
no one there you guys are all scared
go go go go go go go go go go go
okay
i think we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine everything's fine
who's there come face me
fight me i'm here find me
face me kill me i'm here
okay fine then you can't lock the back
door you can't lock the back door
okay and let me prove something to you
this is locked it's locked look
it's it can't open it cause it's locked
no one here okay we're fine
totally fine okay everything's fine you
guys are worried about nothing
you guys are worried over nothing you
guys are worried over nothing
it ain't nothing and they ain't nothing
to worry about
okay all right don't click here but what
about here
creepy we're going to creepy yay
okay
oh boy that's funny face i don't know if
i want face
oh oh boy all right
sure thing here we go
here we go oh no back to baby shrimp no
no but i did so good
but i was doing so good i gotta change
my wi-fi
okay all right let's disconnect from
that one let's go get more free wi-fi
so we don't get swooted all right ah
son of a tit let's have a tet all right
there we go
all right who's got the freebies tp link
good
okay all right let's go back to uh
where's our favorites thanks for
visiting we go here baby shrimp yeah
that's right
yeah you guys are worried over every
little thing and i don't think we need
to be worried about over
every little thing see i don't know they
all go to index or is it like
is it like uh because i found one that
went somewhere but i don't know if that
somewhere was good or not
yeah well this isn't baby shrimp there's
baby shrimp because this one went to
posture
and i don't know if posture is where i
want to go
because everything else is seems to go
the place there was that
fake main it did say it said fake main
so maybe there's something else about
fake main that doesn't
that's not the same as it was before you
know what i mean so if i go back here if
i click on this again
go to evil monster go to the end
then there's gotta be a way man i'm
diving deep into just this one little
thing
and i'm like i don't think i'm in
imminent danger yet because before
before it wasn't until you get like four
codes that things turn
real bad for you so i'm thinking that
hopefully
okay if i go here it goes to fake main
yeah yeah that makes sense it's just
trying to tickle the ball
a little bit about it but there's gotta
be like okay
it's gotta be it was a clever ruse
got it got it i'm nailing this i am
nailing this
i'm nailing this okay twas it
oh oh
okay
but
well there's no not slide
oh i don't want to go to slide
i keep going to the slide you should
leave i just go back
why do i gotta go back to that [ __ ]
and that's not a slide is it
it's fine okay so that was that one
there's got to be something else here
right
oh my god oh
oh index [ __ ] oh god damn it
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die that's how i
die
as i die this is how i die inside i
can only just look around okay
all right well then
okay everything's fine don't worry about
it don't worry about it guys
three face is this gonna go back to face
none of these go anywhere it's all just
a big [ __ ]
okay there's something on this face
besides enter
it's nothing it's nothing
there's gotta be something in my face
okay
all right it's fine i don't know there's
got maybe a different baby shrimp but i
don't know you know what i'm gonna bail
on this
for now i'm gonna check out some of the
other stuff but before i do that
i'm gonna how much money i got i only
got 2.3 that's
not any money how do i get more money
okay i need 25 to be able to get that i
don't
i haven't been hacked in a while that's
the other thing like i haven't been
hacked
which is like weird because usually i
was i was getting hacked a lot when i
first opened this game up
and now suddenly no hacks ugh i don't
know if that's good or bad
man let me try to go back into the
breaking into another wi-fi
let's see you have the fallen crackers
installed let's go wep
let's go um scan
god netflix and chill by myself you know
i kind of want to do that
try the circles in the bottom i don't
think the circles in the bottom actually
do anything okay so
okay all right he's fine this is the
power outage there's nothing to be
worried about
it's totally fine i just gotta go fix it
it's just it's just a fixie wixie all i
got to do is fix the wick see it
nothing to worry about just to fix it
wait okay
fixy-weesy kaboom all right done easy
peasy lemon squeeze me
all right easy peasy nothing to worry
about not a problem
not a problem not a problem easiest
busiest thing i've ever done
anybody in here perfect
all right easy peasy lemon squeezy
yeah okay let's go back here oh it's
amazing that my computer just remembers
where i was
okay let's go back to help starting port
ending port
all right let's go probe x
colon r a colon no colon lr
colon tx colon one n
uh let's go starting port one ending
port
five hundred could not find it
but i just but i just did it change
freak [ __ ] oh wait did it not need
the brackets okay it might not have
needed the brackets
let me try
nope try
this yeah yeah yeah yeah that's gonna
take forever
[ __ ]
[ __ ] anybody out there
anybody out there anybody out there
all right nobody okay we're good back
down
nope sit back down all right
lock the door i did lock the door i did
lock the door and what about the window
there's nothing to see out the window
there's nothing over there
i locked a damn door it's locked see
it's locked okay all right it's fine you
guys are worried over nothing what is
that
why is that in my apartment why do i
have that art that's a weird art okay
all right whatever
you got anything nope
okay you all heard that right no it's
definitely something
okay no port god damn it all right let's
try
501 to 1000.
okay so it's gonna do that yeah i heard
something i definitely heard something
uh i heard some
i don't like what i heard but i heard
something also what is this all about
oh [ __ ] hello murdered throat cut seize
date not released
ah weird i didn't even notice this
missing both missing
slow internet anyone very slow check
network traffic history with isps
servicing the homes of victims
photo from missing hiker's camera does
not match other photos
all bodies found multiple cuts that's
not good
to all tenants if the power goes off
reset the main breaker in the
maintenance closet okay easy enough
the white van my van you talking about
the barrel why would adam help how does
he know so much
let's see all c's drives has a n browser
installed meant for searching the deep
web
okay whatever did i find anything any
hits come on please tell me i got a hit
yes five six one okay so found open port
we need to break into
crack okay the channel was 12. okay
there we go
here we go okay crack
uh 1 x r a l
r t x 1
1 n channel 12 port 561 crack it
oh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah baby
there's a lot of work just to break into
someone's wi-fi but at least they won't
know it's me right
right i don't know if that's how this
works but
i'm hoping i'm i'm hoping
i'm hoping okay so we're making some
progress i feel like a real hacker how
long is this gonna take good god okay
god damn it okay all right i'm
[ __ ]
anybody here nobody here is there a
better place to put my wi-fi my vpn
because eventually i'm going to buy
another vpn because this economy of
scale you just kind of like
exponentially get more and more but
eventually
eventually i'm going to get another vpn
wow why are there two
plates out and why are they not on the
dining table
um is there someone else here do i live
alone
i don't know about that any food
anything else no
nothing okay that's fine yeah and i
haven't been getting hacked
oh password found
denver that's it denver denver was the
password
good god denver wow
thank you for that i'm in good is it
going to be any faster than what i was
doing
probably not all right let's do this
password's not coca-cola and the window
is not open
window's not open what are you talking
about all right
flesh trade are you woke
am i am i woke
i might be woke i don't know if i'm woke
or not but
might be woke i know there's a password
somewhere in thanks for visiting there
has to be
right there has to be something and
thanks for visiting i know that
that for a fact there's got to be a fact
the window is not the window is not open
the window is very clear it's
you're all crazy you're crazy you're
crazy and you're making me crazy i don't
like it
where am i okay uh let's go to you we
went there
rock we rock rock collection's sake
that's got to be something
that seems stupid enough that it's got
to be something
maybe i don't know oh here we go okay
we rock we have many names amphibolite
and dessite
and northocyte there's got to be
something
diatomite dolomite
dolomite wow okay that doesn't work it
works just as laggy as anything else in
this game
or in real life it's so realistic okay
let's no no come on go let's
spread yeah okay there we go one of
these have got to be clickable right
skarn
no webster right
oh come on how is that not all right you
found us
not hard to find we the those come from
the earth we live
understand breaks okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm bookmarking this
page [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] just a bunch of
[ __ ]
no just a bunch of [ __ ] just a bunch
of [ __ ]
just a bunch of [ __ ] all right
nothing
behold the glory
do not try to contact us you will be
ignored we are minerals and cannot write
yeah you know what you're goddamn right
you can't
all right we have no needs there's
nothing on the site
this is this isn't pointless it's
pointless [ __ ]
god damn it i don't want to go to the
doll maker's website
i don't want to do that something tells
me that that's a very bad idea
and i don't want to do that i don't even
know if i saw that
yeah there's nothing here about a doll
maker i saw it before but
someone tells me i don't want to go i
don't want to go there all right um
let's go to [ __ ] oh wait there it is
ah this isn't gonna be good the doll
maker turning
turning young women into sex
[Music]
oh oh hate that oh i hate that
i'll bookmark it but i hate it oh i hate
oh i hate that
oh hate that oh hate that
okay all right hate that okay i hate it
don't stare at me
oh boy the doll maker i believe you know
who i am i have made many slaves for
your enjoyment and have heavily added
heavily to my own collection i've found
a very profitable business and taking
young pretty girls and transforming them
into living sex dolls to fulfill all
your sexual and violent needs
that's horrible no
no no
i don't i don't want to no
no no oh god is there anything
even to try to click that's probably
that's blurred because i turned the
nudity off
i don't even i don't want to do this i
don't want to read about how this is
done you know this is the worst thing
this is the worst thing i'm i'm out of
here
i'm out here i'm out of here yes am i
about to be swatted
i don't know i don't know if like
does connecting to one of the other like
not my
free wifi okay
there was someone at the door there was
someone in my
oh
foreign
hi hello how are you
hello oh [ __ ]
king hell okay all right well okay all
right well
[Music]
help me what are you supposed to do
it was you you did that
you did that i've lost all my progress
you guys suck
put the moneymaker in the fifth floor to
get the most money okay
sure
you did that you did that
okay anyway it's fine it's fine i gotta
get back into it someone said i gotta
put the moneymaker on the fifth floor to
get the most money
god damn it i gotta go get the thing and
then i gotta go back up to my floor and
then i gotta go back down i gotta do all
the [ __ ] again and then i just gotta
worry about not dying
oh that's another [ __ ] thing about
this game it's very hard to
restart god it's so punishing why in the
why in the ass would it be as punishing
as it is like just
you you die so easily and the point of
the game is like to die of course
but then oh my god
it's just this is [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] that's all it is all right so i
need to go back down
there's the freaking lobby actually i
probably shouldn't i probably shouldn't
leave my computer
like tied into something it's all that
come on i bought
what no it charged me twice
what a what a bunch of oh
oh oh that's a one-time thing okay
whatever
fine whatever son of a [ __ ] ass
piece of [ __ ] lord
turn my computer off all right let me
just do this [ __ ]
let me close my door maybe i can lock it
can i lock it nope
no point in that all right let's go get
our delivery
get the [ __ ] outtie oh my god why do
i have to go down so
freaking far yeah that's the thing it is
unbelievably punishing
to die i mean what kind of game is that
if it takes hours and hours to make
progress in the game
that is the most absurdly difficult road
rogue like
in the world then oh man you can't make
a game this vast and then have you reset
every time you die
this is just punishingly primitive
unless there's some way that it's not
like that but i have a funny feeling
it's going to be exactly like that
unless there's a way to like i don't
know remember
things as time goes on i have no idea
maybe maybe maybe not but i have no idea
okay give me that sweet delivery
give me that sweet delivery come on chop
chop chop chop [ __ ] oh come on
we gotta go [ __ ] oh come on let's go
let's go let's go
yes there we go okay and pick that up
for clint get all the way back
because i don't think there's a way to
use the elevator i don't think there is
if there is a way then i don't even know
it oh well that's fine
all right enough of me complaining about
this i'm sure i'm going to be
complaining a lot more later
ugh this is why it's addicting that's
not why it's addicting that's just
annoying
because i mean like i get a scary game
it's supposed to build ambiance and i
get that you're not supposed to die but
especially in the early phases of the
game when you don't know how to play
and you don't know the ways to escape
other thing it's
trial and error so when you have a death
mechanic that resets everything
that you have to explore through trial
and error because
you know i do probably know it it did
say like oh you have to
i think for that guy maybe you have to
turn around and they'll disappear or
something like that or maybe i'm just
dead forever
and like there was no escaping because i
went into the bathroom and i hid and i
thought that would be it but barely not
but
it's just trial and error to reset that
heart is so
so absurdly punishing but we don't know
if 100 that's what it is so
i'm going to withhold judgment until i
see if there's like some kind of
reset mechanic but if there's not that's
going to be a little [ __ ] a little
[ __ ]
all right let's see um boop
sure all right someone said that's gonna
generate the most money i don't know if
that's true but
and also the trial and error of that
finding the place with the most money
only by
going and running around and figuring
out like
maybe this floor is going to be the one
maybe
this seems like [ __ ] anyway all
right
enough of me complaining i'm now back in
place and if that's gonna work then it's
gonna work
lock everybody i locked it everybody
tell everybody that i locked it i did i
did do that
i dunzed it i did that also when am i
supposed to power off my computer when
does that help
i don't even know i don't know anything
i'm making
deep pretty dees money pretty dece
money i think whatever maybe i don't get
hacked until i look at these things is
that what it is
let me test my hacks because i did get
hacked after i
boop because i did get hacked after i
tested these things so
am i just not going to get hacked until
i get to do these things now whatever
probably not that'd be stupid right
that'd be stupid oh let's go into the
deep web
i need to connect to the internet all
right let's do this
let's do this thing baby also why does
this start out small
there we go all right let's do this oh
also my goddamn bookmarks
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever okay let's just go top to bot
let's not go top to bottom let's not go
let's go magistry magistrai
the magistrate uh
proper ways of butchering a human body
oh
all right welcome to the magistrate
the last walk don't know what that is
but okay
okay enter their last walk the steps of
purity maybe you'd be showered by riches
may you be blessed with glorious
sex yes may you find
unending power within these halls
oh okay that's blurred don't like these
that's not okay the first to walk in our
holes
[Music]
okay sure
all right well let's not do those
things that you're talking about let's
not do
listen to bottoms up then i don't know
what you're talking about but i don't
think it's what we're talking about here
all right join the brotherhood i want to
join
please please let me join
please i would love to maybe sponsor key
if you do not who know who we are this
page is not meant for you only the true
elite with a sponsor from a brother may
be one sponsor key um what was the the
web pro marketplayer
perfect enter got it
nailed it this not working
it had no work okay all right well that
didn't work
all right thank you for that i'm sorry
that didn't work
i'll just be on my way then stay around
pal
all right what about just enter can i
just enter
is there some way i can see about this
blessed sex i've heard so much about
oh no
i don't know what does member key uh up
member key is up your butt
mark of the five-fold five time wait
no five times five
equals [ __ ] you 136
136 okay enter
nope don't work okay that don't work all
right let's go back home because this is
barely absolutely a whole lot of nothing
i know about the i know about the the
turning off the
the whatever oh my god i love cats
perfect perfect perfect
there's oh god there's two pedo
community sites i don't want any oh
nope bookmarking nope
that's not what i thought it was going
to be
i'm muffins i'm a dog that is in love
with cats
that's right i know it sounds crazy
because floofy doggos aren't supposed to
breed ooh boy
with sassy kitties but i grew up with
them and have just never really wanted
anything other than do with other
bumpers it just feels so good to be a
big strong
drug loving us okay
oh other dogs don't like it but
something about a cat is just so much
more
sexy can't help myself they're long
tails seductively
sorry about to throw up seductively
swishing effort
flee through the air i'm getting too
excited now need to go to the park i'm
gonna
play now but look at my cats
how about switching my wi-fi just you
know something tells me
it's time something tells me it's time
you're right the window wasn't open
before
you're right you are correct you're
absolutely
yup you're right you're right about that
no one's at my door huh
okay hang on just checking um
nope all right let's get back let's get
back to the good stuff
all right oh i got two free wi-fi's
let's go dw3
all right refresh
uh where am i who am i
all right here we go
boop yep there we are all right my cats
don't want to look at this but i'm
looking for something
something good
there we ah no
no
no i'm not a one kitty
lots and lots of little poofs live with
me and we all share in love nope
we play together eat together sleep
together and so much
we have off don't get too jealous
no no nope nope
nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope just nope
nope nope i'm good
i'm okay up
gonna vomit gotta vomit
nope do you wanna play
no i don't i really don't
nope nope nope nope you know i'm out i'm
out i'm out i'm out i'm out
nope nope nope not doing it
not happening ain't gonna do it to me
not doing it nope
i am very sorry i went to there i am
here
oh
i think the police are going to come to
my house now they're not actually going
to go over to
me in the game they're just coming
straight to me they're they're cutting
through the [ __ ] they're just gonna
go
arrest me which frankly i'd i'd be fine
with that if i could be
put any distance between me and that guy
no
i'm okay i'm okay just no pool's closed
nope nope okay all right let's go to the
let's go to the storefront for breast
milk
let's do that let's do that everybody
we're going to the breast milk store
uh next up we're gonna go to [ __ ] pills
just any sort of bodily function
that's what that's what i nope
nope just as soon as i get in here milk
matt nope
i have a huge collection of milk from a
number of different girls new bags as
often as i can get them for your
pleasure i'm going to vomit i might
vomit only buy from the sexiest mommies
in there
nope nope nope
no nope no
uh-uh no
i might vomit no
no
oh my god no i don't want more milk
pictures
i don't want it this is the only thing
to click on i don't want it
i don't want any of this i don't want
i don't want nothing to do with it
oh god no
nope nope nope nope that's
nope that's a big old nope there none of
these are clickable i wasted my time
what oh
wait oh hey look it's a z oh look
well well well well well all right
9 20 004 got it
perfect got it wow look at that let me
switch let me just get it i'm just going
to disconnect
oh my window's open that's not good does
anybody at my door
okay well i found the number
whoa whoa
why is my there we go wait put it put
that bad boy up
get it get it up there hmm my window
doesn't seem to want to close anymore
welp that's a problem that's
definitively a problem
huh so um
oh that was in my opinion not worth it
and i guess i can't close my window
anymore
welp
might vomit my might abs absolutely
okay anyway now that we've got that out
of the way what does it mean when my
window is partially
open what does that mean did someone
just come by and crack it open for some
flipping reason
like why what is the point why would you
do that what are you out of your gourd
what are you even
talking about oh my god okay so
oh for a second there i thought that guy
was just going like this ugh
all right so we got one number one we
need eight and a lot more money
okay okay
i don't know what to do about if they
got you can save the game can i
how do i save how do i save the game
and what does it matter if i save the
game
where how do i save how do i save
tell me please i need to know
uh do i exit the main menu
can i go back in how do i save
i don't know i don't know
i don't know how do i save guys you
gotta tell me
how do i save i know it's a warning i
know it's a warning
under bed under bed und i save under my
bed
that doesn't make any sense at all
what what
oh is there something under my bed no
okay
all right under the bathroom
under the bathroom okay check the bat
why would i check the bathroom
what's gonna be in my bathroom
well you can save and it's not all that
far you can
save there's a i shouldn't be shouting
in here
there's a way to save there is a way to
save
like there's got to be there there is a
way to save
because it says it says continue on the
it says continue so i'm assuming
but i got i got one of the numbers
so you know did it autos
it says continue on the main page
there's got to be a way
gotta be away it's gotta be a way
right right yes
exactly did i copy that right
b cb
920 e double four so i copied it
[ __ ] god damn it oh [ __ ] all right
oh my god
oh my god i scared the piss out of me
all right we got this oh that's fast
okay all right way
did i get any money for that
uh i don't know no no no i gotta good
disconnect
hang on disconnect okay ah
i'm in physical pain i'm in pain
pain
it's not all f4 i know it's not that's
the oldest joke in the book
i've done the internet before
the power button does not save i
guarantee that
if i just go to menu
let's save
no no no no skip this it's fine
it's it must have saved right
maybe maybe maybe it has
see yes okay continue but if i die
is it still gonna like [ __ ] me over
i'm losing my mind lose my mind i lose
my goddamn mind
i'm losing
f4 it must be alt f4 everyone's saying
alt
f4 it must be how that's how to save
right the game auto saves your progress
every 15 minutes
oh pro tip
wait no that's bad but if that's that
then i didn't get this
am i gonna keep the code why is the
protip there
why is that incredibly important piece
of information there
now
no
we gotta go back into the milk supply
oh god why
why it saves every 15 minutes yes now i
know
now i know now i know all right this
code better still be here and it better
be the same goddamn code if they change
over
i'm gonna be incredibly pissed
okay all right yes it's still there okay
it's fine it's fine everything's fine
everyone's panicking over nothing
everyone's screaming yelling
raving it's all fine we got it we got it
baby
it's fine it's fine it's fine we got it
it's all good we've got one code the
game may
save but i think if you get a game over
you're still dead
ed
yeah let's go [ __ ] pills let's go to
ship pills everybody
the door is it's locked i don't know
after the save i actually don't know if
the door is locked or not i'm pretty
sure it's locked
oh it was not locked okay good good call
good call good call oh boy [ __ ] pills
perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect
okay all right home shop special contact
process
i don't think there's anything in there
probably not
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be there all
right top seller trial pack
let's do the trial pack let's go to buy
let's go buy this bad boy
let's also switch our wi-fi pretty soon
error loading your card okay all right
then let's
let's switch and let's go back
yeah no i'm nervous too i'm just as
nervous as you are
i'm nervous i'm nervous i'm nervous
i'm very nervous once i get 25 though i
am going to um
i'm gonna i'm gonna try
to buy another vpm and then place that
and then i can be making more money and
then hopefully i'll be able to get the
key
identifier and that's going to be that's
going to be very good
okay contact me how i handle my feces my
diets
my gut is good yeah okay all right how
about special sale
ugh god why are there
it would not shock me if there was
actually a market for poop pills out
there
it would not shock me not in the least
not even a little bit
not even close i would be unsurprised
okay so i highly about i highly doubt
that any of this
dried fecal powder why is this image
broken why is this image broken is there
something special about this image
is this something talking god damn it
again
scares me so badly all right come on
bring it on
and why aren't i making money from this
all right we got this we got this okay
come on bring it on you think this is
all i need
easy i don't know whatever okay
easy peasy oh yes i got money
yes give me money the money is mine
okay let's check see if anything weird
going on
anything weird nothing weird yet
nothing weird okay seems to be okay all
right
oh jiggly a little bit okay we're very
cl
that was me right yeah that was me okay
we're very close to being able to get
what we need but let me move the
let me move the wi-fi one more time to
uh
right outside probably not the best idea
but here we go
okay got that do another three free
wi-fi see i don't know if you cycle back
to the wi-fi it's also going to be a
problem for you because it could be
and that would like force me to have to
hack into other people's wi-fi's
which would be bad i guess but you could
run the hack while you're doing other
stuff so i guess there is some
multitasking going on here but
i just don't know i just don't know
the [ __ ] are poop pills some people do
do poop pills there there's such a thing
as poop
transplants all right let's just start
from the bottom all this is gonna ah
god damn it again again
ah frick you man freak you
all right fine fine fine yes it's fine
it's fine it's fine
okay good enough oh boy i got this one
memorize
seven nine zero 79
got it nailed it oh [ __ ] i'm so
good let me buy more of those back doors
because that's those are those are
pretty good because i am going to get
hacked so why not
right oh wait i can buy another vpn
give me that give me that sweet vipin
all right give me a vipin i wanna
yes give me more give me fuel give me
fire give me that's what i desire
okay lulpy disc what is that oh that's
gonna
uh take forever to ship at least it's
fine lol
what does that even mean what
huh okay anyway uh
no it's fine okay it's totally fine
yeah it's totally fine it's totally fine
skeleton woo
all right so let's go okay unable to
connect to that one
so no bathroom cams thankfully because
frankly i didn't even want that
that would have been the worst thing in
the world all right uh
don't work don't work i don't want to go
to a rape video site that claims to be
100 real i don't want that
i don't want that don't be real don't be
ah
oh god no
nope nope nope
nope nope this is the worst thing no
no no no no i hate it i hate it i don't
see a code i don't see a code i don't
see a code
don't see a code no code no code i'm out
i'm outtie uh
why why
oh close the back door the back door was
closed
i think i don't know i don't know it's
closed it's closed
everything's closed everything's locked
oh
good god it is closed it's closed
it's closed maybe i don't know it's
close
it's very clearly closed you guys are
out of your mind it's the same people
that are yelling
for hit alt f4 all right
burned at the stakes i guess oh did i
not go to bathroom cams
i mean not that i want to do
nope nothing there
did my oh did my package get delivered
yep okay i gotta go uh i gotta go get
that oh let me disconnect from my that'd
be important
nope come on now boink okay all right
getting up
shoo bitty whoopidy let's go out let's
get outta here oh unlucky giddy-outy i
should've probably checked the door
before i
just blundered wanderingly so smoothly
out there
all right it's fine no we ain't dead
we're not dead we're not dead we're fine
actually we're doing wonderfully
we're doing real good i don't know if
we're doing real good
but we're doing pretty good which is
about the best that i could possibly
hope for
so if i can get my vpns rolling i should
be making a lot of dosh
because it said there was a limit you
could get woo [ __ ] you could get a limit
of five i think
but if i could get all five if i could
survive enough to get all five then i
can get some of the preventative
measures like the
police scanner and also the noise
emotion cams
all that good [ __ ] so hopefully i'll be
able to survive this
but i don't know i don't know all right
we oh is it already there i think it's
already there
perfect give me thank you another vpn
for me
although i gotta run all the way back up
and freaking delivery why why is that a
mechanic why can't i just pick it up
from the alley
and then use it immediately because
that's kind of what i want to do
whatever all right so i guess it's just
a random guess of where this is going to
go and
what does that drip how's that drip
yeah whatever wherever this is going to
go and whatever good it's going to do me
i'm going to try outside
on the balcony as high up as i can go if
i can place it just on any wall anywhere
i guess that's going to do good for me
no i'm not going to get killed
oh all that fork closes the window oh
well
i don't know are you sure are you sure
are you sure about that you think
you think maybe it does because i don't
know if it do i think he might be
i think he might be full of poop all
right here we go
room 203 go there i don't know if i want
to go to room 203 now that you said it
like that
all right whatever maybe maybe put it
outside i'll go down i'll go to 203 i
trust you
i trust you i'm going to 203 now because
that's what i would figure this
apartment is so big also i'm not going
to question why there aren't anyone else
walking around this apartment but this
apartment is so big
you would think that there would be
other people in this area that were
going about their daily lives and doing
their own daily things and not being an
[ __ ]
four okay two more down i don't know
what's going to go on at 203 but i
i'm gonna see let's see what's going on
here 203
oh i can't even go on two well that's
[ __ ] i can't even go
all right i don't know if he's gonna
make any money there
all right let's see if that's making me
any good money uh
can't go to 203. there's got to be a way
to do the elevator
right because why else would it exist
why else would it be there that one's
there okay
so that's good i don't know if that's
the best place to actually go for that
but yeah you all it's like a chat's just
a bunch of like
of uh uh hopping on the bandwagon if
someone says something that sounds
relatively like informative woof
[ __ ] audi i'm [ __ ] audi i'm
[ __ ] outie i'm out i am
[ __ ] out i am out i'm gone
i'm out [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i don't know where to go i don't know
what to do
i'm this is my home now this is where i
live
and this is where i'll be
yep this is where this is where i exist
now
yep everything's fine don't worry about
it everything's fine what are you
talking about if you're worried about it
you're stupid everything's
fine
everything's fine everything's 100
percent fun what are you talking about
everything's fine
pray what do i pray oh
hold it
okay and pray
is he still gonna be there oh what the
hell
what is that what does that do oh that's
like oh that's like my
my jiggle meter i can only i can only
hold it jiggled
so much well that's weird
oh that's weird oh this is a bat i don't
like this mechanic
i don't like that all right well time to
go see if he's still there
do i not have my flat i didn't even i
don't even have my flashlight
cause that's right because i i started
this game back up before i got that
okay well here's hoping he's not there
you know but maybe he is maybe he is
right cool all right
well all right is there a basement i
don't know
i don't even want to know the answer to
that i do not want to know
well if he's still there i'm in trouble
if he's not
well i'm i'm even more paranoid
because i don't know if that would make
him go away you know would it
all right cross your fingers everybody
cross your fingers
cross your fingies cross them cross them
hard
here we go
okay all right we're fine everything's
good
hello okay
everything's good great
oh no i don't have my flashlight i don't
know where's my flies
i don't know where am i okay i'm where's
the bed's right here
it's got to be right there so
flashlight's gotta be oh [ __ ]
i can't find it okay i'll just go
without it i don't need it
i can make my way i can't even find the
door i forgot to grab my flashlight
[ __ ] can't even find the door
it's dark okay
where am i oh i'm back in my apartment
how did that happen
i can't see [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay i've got to be able this guy i've
got to find
my flashlight okay i'm right by the bed
i'm on the opposite side of the bed
it's got to be right there right gotta
be somewhere
come on come on where are you
oh boy yep i've lost it uh okay
okay there's a window nope okay all
right
i'm just i'm just boned i can't go
anywhere
i'm boned and
forever bone down shall remain okay i
think this is the door
so where'd the door go
uh oh uh oh where it just said well
everything just disappears how can it
just disappear like that
okay wait okay oh my god this is
flipping impossible okay i open the door
walking through i'm in the hallway now
why am i not moving
one minute
oh whoa what well there's a light oh
it's
i'm at the door i'm at the door with the
window right right
how do i okay uh if you don't pick up
the flashlight you're just eternally
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i did am i did i go to the elevator
accidentally is this the elevator
oh [ __ ] okay let's assume i just went to
the elevator
complete 180.
so
how what the [ __ ] how can i not
where what how am i [ __ ] back here
okay let me just
this makes no sense this makes no sense
where
am i i don't know where the [ __ ] i am
what the [ __ ] is going how is this
how where would i be
oh no
i can't go straight back
the footsteps just stop where
am i i went into the hallway
what the [ __ ]
this makes no sense this
that's the police but the power's out so
that can't be after me
i don't know i don't know man what the
[ __ ] game developers uh i found a
bug i went out in the hallway
i can't
now i'm lost
i can't [ __ ] believe this
no i don't have a flashlight i'm
pressing
f it doesn't work cause i didn't pick it
up
cause i loaded up a save before i picked
it up and i even talked about it
when i was walking in and now i'm just
i'm just certainly [ __ ]
no you you you goddamn fools here if i
could
oh jesus oh i'm gonna pull everything
off yeah i'm
pressing f it doesn't [ __ ] do
anything cuz i didn't pick it up
all right i guess there's something else
we can do we just gotta
oh [ __ ] go away this is nothing else to
do
well developer seems like your game's a
little [ __ ] broken huh
all right [ __ ] hell
all right let's go back into it i guess
great
that doesn't make any sense because i
went out my front door
there's no i couldn't walk farther than
two feet i couldn't walk farther than
two feet in any direction and then there
was that weird [ __ ]
light what the [ __ ] was that it was a
hallway
how could i not get down a [ __ ]
it wouldn't there were no footsteps
didn't make any goddamn sense
didn't make any goddamn sense now i have
to start it's not from the beginning but
it might as well be
i'm a little heated i'm heated i'm
heated
no
i've been in the dark for 15 minutes oh
no they're just
okay now i can't even find the [ __ ]
window
okay just so i can [ __ ] see something
i'm going outside
may oh what if what if what if i pick
this up then i'll see the glow
on the nightstand where yes yes
okay so the oh wait
i thought i saw the glow yes
so if that's right there this is on the
nightstand where the flashlight is
yeah yes oh my god
ah
now what the [ __ ] light did i see
what was the light what did i what
nothing it's fine everything's fine
everything's fine just chunk
okay all right oh my god
ah
see that was me using my brain i used my
brain
real goodly i used my big
brain i used my big brain to get
the the right thing and then i did it
and then i did it and then everyone was
like
good job everyone was like good job and
that was me
that's what i did i did it okay
okay oh
boy now so let's go back on duty
let's go to duty and let's see what else
we can buy
okay all right
i need a motion sensor eventually
we're fine let's get back into this
we're back in the game
everything's good we're back into it
we're feeling great
i'm feeling great you're feeling great
we're doing this
all right let's burn it up [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you all right come on bring it on
all right we got easy peasy
peasy oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
all right didn't give me any money
though that's fine
i'll open up this i'll buy another a
couple another of these things
hmm wait you have to pay for an emotion
emotional or that's so
stupid all right whatever burn at the
stake let's get it boss
let's get it let's do it oh i didn't
lock the door that is
that is definitely a true that's a for
true that's a fortress i didn't lock the
door
oop good good go on yeah now that's open
is anybody at the back door
nope okay all right we're good all right
that is a dad to sight okay no going
there
easy peasy easy peasy
easy peasy easy person
hacker group portal site probably the
best place to go
in the shadow underweb thing nope
doesn't work
okay making a good bit of money
we making as much money as we were
before yeah oh we're making way a lot of
money we're making a good bit of money
okay that's good dream place
i didn't want to go to dream place
anyway to be perfectly honest i'm
actually happy this hack is happening
someone's trying to protect me to be
perfectly honest
okay all right let's do this
oops [ __ ]
easy oh give me that money
yeah give me that money all right let me
buy another one of these okay
that didn't i heard that
heard something what's going on over
there um
who's over there huh who is there
who's there somebody there no okay all
right then
is it busy is it busy
all right um actually i don't know if
that actually
continued because i got hacked to be
perfectly honest i don't want to go
and i don't want to go to the bathroom
cans oh god
okay that didn't work good frankly good
frankly
excellent frankly amazing in fact
let's try the bathroom cams
i know i hear rustling too i hear a lot
of rustling all over the place good that
didn't work
either
um paranoid perinata
perinati okay drone spy drone footage
invading people's privacy that's not
good
that's not good at all but let's see oh
good drone spy i've been a drone
hobbyist for many years logged in
anything
videos okay are you the guy that flies
my deliveries for me because that's
awfully nice
i'm damn good at flying okay collection
of videos don't really care wallet
and blah blah blah don't care don't care
spy for me
come on what do we got what do we got
what do we got what do we got what have
we got there's no way to lock the window
that's just impossible that's literally
impossible okay drawn
okay this doesn't help me doesn't seem
to be anything here that i can click
seems to be totally nothing okay let's
let's just because i'm paranoid
let's disconnect from this wi-fi check
for any weird stuff
check this okay that's good
door is definitely locked cool pick this
up
let's put it back outside for some
reason i don't know why
but some reason okay go back in here
i wish i could lock the back door that
is creepy
that's really creepy why do i have much
creepy heart in my house
why am i such a weirdo why can't i close
my window
i don't know all right whatever anybody
in my bathroom
i don't think there would be anybody in
here just checking very paranoid
okay here we go all right connect back
again eventually i'm gonna have to get
that
uh wi-fi cracker because i don't under i
don't know if
yeah i don't know if that's gonna be
enough
there's got to be a better way to make
money than just the vpn thingamabobbers
right there's got to be a better way to
make money
okay whatever moving on we're making
progress i'm not going to complain about
too much
buy another one of these bad boys bad
buzz
i mean is the motion detector even worth
it if you can just if you could just
like
do something the bathroom cam didn't
work there might be a different time of
night
when it does work why can't i oh i'm why
can't i
or no i don't want to go to spy for me i
want to go home let me go home
get me to home no i want to go home i
don't care about what you're spying on
uh check site source code
that makes sense is that something i can
do
is that something oh it is something i
can do
i did not know that all right then i i
had no idea
wow really all right let's go family
drug shop your friendly family drug shop
friendly friendly family drug shop nope
nothing there
man there's got to be something else get
your vpn to level two i
might i might but
how about flame through the fire and the
flame
lock everything i'm trying man i'm
trying if i
could lock more i would unable to
connect man there's a whole lot of
nothing going on here
hmm vpn level five
i guess i don't think that's going to
improve my money at all but i'm going to
get it anyway just in case
i am here or am i haven't i done that
one i don't think that one actually goes
anywhere bathroom door keeps opening and
closing i don't believe you
i don't believe you okay that didn't
work either okay let's disconnect
let's move again just because i'm super
paranoid
okay super paranoid where did i put it
outside
okay okay
actually let me just put it by my desk i
haven't done that in a while it's
probably gonna be fine
all right connect again tp-link okay
that didn't work
yeah i know all the tips
yeah it's weird that a lot of the tips
are just in the loading screen of the
game i mean there's so many things that
i would love to be able to
you know can you go home already why
can't i go home
what the hell that was weird i don't
know why that was happening
i don't like it i don't like it
all right let's go home go home already
get the wi-fi cracker i will get the
wi-fi cracker that is next on my list to
do
i will definitely do that okay um
keepsake dismemberment preservation of
dead tissue
why are the only websites that work on
this all about like dead bodies and [ __ ]
ugh oh god
oh i don't like it i don't like it at
all
i do not like it oh wait we got
something we got a hit
we got a hit bing bong what did they do
uh that's usually the wait did that
bob
what where did he do it
it bonged and i i remember
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you man
yeah good okay [ __ ] it what i remember
that doing something but i don't see
anything
there's nothing in the source code
there's just nothing anywhere it says
it's doing the bong
what does that mean i am looking at the
notepad it didn't it didn't do anything
for the notepad
that didn't do anything for the notepad
i don't know
i don't know man okay there's something
about this website i'm just gonna
i'm gonna save it i don't think there's
anything in here
okay the process form jar
that did nothing
no nothing okay nothing all right
i don't know man i don't know i don't
know
check the desktop oh that's right wait
wait wait were you right
you're right uh key four oh
18 that's right [ __ ] come on
what was that what was that noise wait
what was that noise
wait disconnect from a wi-fi that's
right that's right i forgot that that
was a thing that could happen
still good okay we're fine everything's
fine
i've got two codes i've got two
codes
two three one e seven five f okay
boink got it i've got two codes
i've got two codes
okay i've got two codes okay i think
what i'm gonna have to do is i'm gonna
have to get the wi-fi cracker
thing eventually i gotta connect to this
one
for a little bit so i'm just gonna go
ahead and do that now just because
i'm getting paranoid about being on the
same wi-fi for too long
vpn level one i don't think that means i
make more money i think there's just
less hacks
nah it doesn't seem to be making me any
more money
ah okay anyway sorry i just needed to
scream for a bit
oh okay check your desktop i already got
it i got i got i got i gotta get it okay
i've got two
codes two codes two codes
okay
all right come on come on come on come
on come
on and boom got it okay move that over
there easy peasy
all right done and done let's disconnect
from this let's get up from here
run i'm leaving
i'm outtie okay i'm out i saw that okay
goodbye just gotta go stretch my legs
good bye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye what am i supposed to do
to those guys
i all i know is that running away as far
as i can worked
and i don't want to tempt fate
okay all right it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine yeah what what is
what does it do
two of ten codes oh my god ten
codes why okay i don't know if this is
gonna work i don't know if this is how
this works
okay all right it looks good to me
okay
count to thirty is that all i gotta do
is that the oh was that the one where
you turn around and you count to 30.
i need to read those documents again
because those documents
were probably important for me to read
and i did not read them enough but
whatever it's all good it's
all fine
just don't look at him okay that doesn't
make any sense though
that doesn't make any sense oh do not
look at him
it's just the internet it's not like
there's actual demons here
are there
[Laughter]
you still there buddy oh good okay all
right great good to know
locky locked it anybody there
okay all right we're fine
everything is a-okay
perfect everything's great everything's
great guys
i'll put this by the window boop okay
all right all right
let's uh let's scan up something
all right scan oh sorry weep scan
should go back to the alley for a while
you know that's all right
what was the commands again i've already
forgotten probe
yeah okay all right
sorry i'm okay all right probe
uh 7z zeta
uh polio uh harry potter
uh lucas five five
xavier what was the other ones was it
one
to a thousand go okay so that's gonna go
for a while but while i'm doing that i
can connect to one of these
other ones
okay it's just a power outage that's all
it is
that's all it is it's all it is
nothing wrong not that anyone's doing
anything about that that's just
happening by itself
totally natural totally normal totally
normal
e okay anybody here okay close
lock all right good is that scan still
going
doubt it oh it is going wow amazing okay
all right so we're gonna get that one
but in the meantime
we should be okay on these ones just to
keep moving
if i can keep moseying along that's what
i need
come on go god it never goes home let's
close out of this
try again go home there we go we got a
port
okay so uh crack
seven zeta p four harry potter
lexicon five five xavier
nope five xavier uh
channel port 670 boom
boom okay let's go try that all right
let's go to legion
let's try legion man i i haven't even
gotten close to any of these sites
yeah some of them didn't work and some
of them i was diving deep on and i
i don't know if it was the proper place
to
go for it but oh well that's nothing
okay nothing on that one
we got cracked password is falcon let's
just go over and hop over to that one
falcon connect got it okay cool cool
cool cool
uh let's go home go home go home go home
refresh
bathroom door is open i don't think
you guys are out of your gourd it's not
open
no it's not
nah it's not open you guys you got so
crazy you guys are crazy
yeah you're out of your mind you got
your gourd you had your gourd
your guys gourds are all over the place
you guys need to keep your gourds in
in intact guys keep your gourds in a
bottle
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine oh
i don't want to do this whatever you're
selling i don't want it we are gray
we walk in the shade are these the
neutral lights
from the neutral zone futurama anybody
furious loudest cranius centrum will you
walk in the shade
yes i shall i will walk in your shade
i'll check get out
okay learn the three walls of interiors
sure
let's go lattice i want to know lattice
about my interior
talking god damn it okay all right ow
my heart why would you do that
[Music]
oh i'm so good all right see ya all
right
the walls at your sides the gray the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the [ __ ] okay
i learned
i learned i learned so goodly i learned
real goodly like so much good about my
learning
okay man i don't know when they're gonna
send hitmen after me
like why would they do that i'm just
trying to get into the thing that
everybody gets into
apparently why are they so worried about
me
okay the center of your ways the media
the [ __ ] the below the
the wumble dump the oh wait
was that just this is this well that
didn't do me any good
okay
the enemas what's in my anus
i i don't know enough about the end of
my anus can you please tell me
anybody okay the void of emotion within
yourself yeah that sounds like my
butthole
when mastered you have become gray no no
that doesn't sound quite like my
butthole
numb to the zeitgeist of our world now
that sounds like my butthole
all right come on please just give me go
into the shade now your house is built
my house is built in my anus
oh no all right
if you change your mind and you do not
wish to become gray you may well return
to your life
what am i gray now is that just it
well there's got to be something else
about this there's got to be there's got
to be something else about this goddamn
game
nope it's just this this is all there
was well all right anything in the
source code
no no all right fine there was
no point to this all right is anybody
there
anybody in the bathroom
skewey
that's fine okay everything's fine
i don't know how long i can stay on this
particular wi-fi before the police catch
onto me
so i'm gonna have to crack another one
eventually but i don't know
wish i had a police scanner i'm probably
overdoing it with the amount of times
that i
i changed through things but just i
don't know i don't want to risk it
okay where are we going uh nope
don't like that don't like that no don't
like that
no don't like that i do not like
that i do not like that okay little
friends
nope nope nope don't nope nope
just nope nope i don't want to nope
don't nope
don't want to join nope nope do not no
nope nope nope nope
nope nope just nope just nope
nope nope nope just gonna nope out of
that one all right no one here
seems so far so good but i'm i'm getting
paranoid about the the
the the uh the wi-fi that i'm on so i'm
going to disconnect that one
uh disconnect and i'm going to find a
different one
let's see this one was by the window so
we just got to go
over there okay let's just do it right
here
okay then we'll just crack again
crack if i can remember all the the
things is gonna be easier
wep scan no door what are you talking
about
what are you what are you talking about
what
what do you see why am i seeing you
everyone's going no and i didn't see
nothing did you guys see something i
didn't see
all right okay
[Applause]
okay all right let's um let's probe
n1y6 oh i should probably that's right i
should probably write these passwords
down huh that's probably important
uh 5b r4 probe that bad boy one to a
thousand baby oh come on oh i didn't
capitalize the y
prop
valid port number what
what i wonder without it
what
there we go oh yeah the minus you don't
need
oop don't looking i'm not looking
one two three
four five six
seven eight nine
11 12 13
14 15 16
17 18 19
20 21 22
23 24 25
26 27 28
29 and 30.
it worked
i don't feel good about it but it worked
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wait okay wait crack uh
wait let's just do this so i don't have
to type that [ __ ] again crack
on channel eight
eight port [ __ ] 608
got it
check the front door just to be safe you
know i might but
i think i'm okay i think i think it's
all good i think you know god just go
home
i think it's okay i don't think i need
to run to nine i don't think i need to
run a night with those i'm pretty sure i
don't need to run an eye
i'm almost 100 positive that i don't
need to run and hide all right number
station
don't like that um
please tell me this is actually going to
go somewhere because i'm not
uh nope not go anywhere but i'll be able
to buy another vpm soon
so i can get more money i guess that's
the important thing right friday okay
password two what even was that
what what that friday what was that two
was that
it was to d i think it was that was d d
five nine
friday
don't take my money
oh boy here we go
got it got money too okay i'm gonna buy
another vpn i'm gonna hook up to this
thing
we're gonna go friday friday friday
and it's in a friday okay we got that
we're connected to the new vpn we're
gonna
shop for this and then
after that we're gonna save up for the
motion sensor because god damn you know
i need that bad boy
okay all right we're fine everything's
fine
okay totally fine totally fine
everything's good
because that bad boy's gonna be coming
in let's keep going on this bad boy
right here
and let's make some progress
god damn it there's gonna be so many
freaking numbers that i don't even
understand
i mean eventually if i get all those i
should be fine
i don't know let's go to mutilation i
don't want to go to mutilation
please don't i don't want my poor
innocent eyes my virgin eyes please
i don't want to go to mutilation no it's
a thing
oh god that's so much blurred oh no
oh no oh god it's the one with the uh
it's the ball sack
let's click on the balls let's click on
the balls
oh boy make money oh hell yeah
i wanna make money being mutilated
perfect okay anything here so i gotta
tickle the scrotum the right way
oh boy all right so that's not there
this doesn't work that's there
following who am i following man if i
log into my twitch account on this thing
would it actually go forward with it
[Laughter]
i bet it would i bet it would i bet it
would
sign into mutilation how about we don't
do that how about we don't do
that let's not do that i can't even go
to bras
i can't go to log in can't even go to
token
how do i join how do i join
i don't know how to join i don't know i
don't even know
all right here we go join mutilation you
do not lose this token
oh i don't want to pay money for this
well i don't have an email in this thing
do i gotta put in my real email cause i
ain't gonna do that
no way i'm gonna do that okay all right
uh
it's a dick waggler
at tickle tickle me scrote dot
org join baby
is it gonna work no wallet oh [ __ ]
no wallet found please try again i will
not
i for one will not i'm gonna search for
tickle scrote give me that
sweet scrote tickling you know what i'm
here for all right i'm out of here
there's probably something here but i
just i don't know how i'd be able to
find it
i don't know how
when are they gonna send that assassin
after me honestly i don't know
all right so that was nothing but it was
something i mean
mutilation was a site that i could go to
oh no i already went to the number
station that's already not going to do
anything
but it's past midnight so maybe some of
the new websites have opened up
time goes a lot slower in this one than
it did in the last one why did i get out
of that
i just need faster internet speed is the
other thing that i need shadow market
oh my new vpn my new vpn yay
i gotta go get my vpn guys hang on i
gotta go i got i'll be right back i
gotta go get my vpn
i gotta go get it i didn't write down
that other password but you guys
remember what the password was right
probably let's go get my vpn yeah
i'm gonna make more money i can't wait i
can't wait
all right let's do this
what was the uh what was the what was
the um what was
both the wi-fi name and the password for
the um
the first one that i cracked it was like
door handle or something like that
dem dahmer flump or dink i think it was
flump or dink you guys remember flumper
dink does that sound familiar to you
i think it was plumper dink pretty sure
it was slumper dink and whatever
i got a vpn with my name on it yahoo
okay use business emails from websites
oh that's smart that's real smart but i
don't remember half those
oh there's so much [ __ ] that you
need to write down
all right just give me my [ __ ] give me
my good [ __ ]
clint perfect no one would know that
no one would pick that up all right
vibian
vivian all right
close your damn door i don't know it
closes on its own it doesn't need my
help to close it
it just closes
all right hope this oh there's not a
friendly visitor waiting for me
i bet there's gonna be oh i bet there's
gonna be
where's the best place falcon that was
it falcon i was close bumperdink was
pretty close
where's the uh where's the next best
place to put this vpn
because i got it on five and two and
that seems to be working out relatively
okay for me
but if there's another place and it's
even better let me know don't be here
no one why
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
help me why
why
[Music]
but why though this game would take
hundreds of hours to beat
i don't want to play this game for
hundreds of hours
[Music]
all right anyway i think that's enough
for this for now
i'm just fumbling in the dark and i
don't know how to play
good god it's it's good it's tense it
really is
but the the punishment
see i don't know why that hitman was
after me i don't know why was it just
coincidence you guys might know for some
reason you guys might know but i don't
know
how would i avoid that i don't open the
door how would i even know he was there
there's nothing clear
[Music]
anyway if i had to say anything about
the game very scary very tense
not enough information okay anyway
that's all i'll say about it so
that's all for now thank you everybody
so much for watching this has been fun
and good to get back into streaming
again
and uh expect more games coming soon if
i find out more about this game i might
play it again but for now
i'll leave it where it lies so thank you
everybody so much for watching you all
have a wonderful day
you take care of yourselves and each
other send a lot of love all across the
world and have a lovely day thank you
everybody for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye bye bye guys
bye